hey guys I'm so excited because we were
going to the place that I wanted to go
for I can't even tell you how long since
I may be moved to California it was
supposed to be a surprise and it was a
surprise for like a couple days and then
I figured it out
Jonathan well I have you had to be
prepared you had to know all the
information going into this I knew all
the information I know all the
information and were on her life
you
and
Oh
my goodness
maybe YouTube I don't know I'll just be
your first time
oh my God thank you my doing I'm so
happy I want my car Granum everything
might have been a while ago plus honda
we can all go
so my first time I brought liver
sentence
oh my Ruff Ryders y'all me me it looks
good
shall we sure what's your pill wait I'm
getting ready okay there's Jen on their
head okay no show us your office it's
incredible or do you not dessert did you
make that last night
no it's from a kilt but I noticed that
it doesn't wrap all around my body yeah
it looks amazing
let's go blue double then I have on open
have super duper - purple - Wow he's
awesome
don't make Lego it's like a legend I
never got into Lego no thanks not
Makarios
in the mirror this way go for free and
Bry saloner it will get this later
well I don't get I need not to put on my
mini big body
guess what today can we just get one
step it's like a couple of em real quick
I don't know sure serious one I just
need some horrible let's do that
took my my tan jacket shoes or this
thing it's Greeners man it's still in
here
what is that thing this is my heart leg
erlang yes change my outfit I was a
simple face looks good oh yeah that's
great
actually that's like my face you're so
little
show us a mat oh yeah
where they go I love Legoland what all
my hairs on that looks great that's like
in the morning there's my Marie here you
made this for me
yeah me and I made it great maybe we put
all the pieces of why it took so long
that's great I love it they know do you
love like a man I know you like me
he looks just like him yeah we turned
his hair Popeye thank you you got done
and that means you look great wait you
created these specifically a service
welding the t-bone steak no that's it
oh my goodnes a big Xbox controller this
is the Xbox game League game center Wow
lost our friends again a little bit at
discoloring pizza they go happiness I
don't talk about what I did to you
that's wrong I spilled a drink over me
in 2009 big head remember that game
Katamari Damacy yes we had a kata Mari
ball one a little guy pushing it around
and I found it and I have a photo of it
and I'll send a few down
okay it makes me so sad that they're all
discolored thank you so sad if you can
bend on it grow up and you drop it in
there the hell this looks so cool I'm
glad my drink has a handle
I'm sure this doesn't work there's a
lizard is real anyway sure so excit is
like oh my god there's a Yeti oh no I
told you
Oh get down there okay we're gonna light
it yet
oh good Mike you'll have the Sasquatch
in the plant I hope I know I look at all
this cotton I still need to build my
bonsai dream that looks so good right
there - who wants green and it's now
teal okay I guess what you did you if
you got this from street level it would
be like a horror movie about big bean
my water but it looks good real clean
rope it says like a what I can't even
make this stuff up butterfly on you I've
been training him the whole time we've
been here
he's licking you and giving me live like
Maddie and I just took so many photos I
got to show you some right now
you know that uh I butterfly those made
of Lego bricks real I know it was named
the familiar Lego bricks this is a great
shot I could have been great I just need
to get them all in one so I don't have
to play anymore
where's my ball ass is this level I've
lost track of everything that's going on
ah dot
this dumpster spraying oh wait do they
really spray from quick though that's
his but his neck here you go here things
this okay do you want it this way
what swings I'm yelling sweep that's
good she's gonna look like I was filming
I might have actually caught the
hole-in-one
so I got a - who's gonna win who won
Edie
congratulations thank you add one horn
let's go see some more like a right did
you take my photo in front of me
oh you gotta wait about the painting a
great because it's the most
PACA week we're gonna get our bricks
engraved I'm gonna get my name on it as
you going to get I think his name and
Lincoln done such beautiful back so I'll
bring these up for you guys right over
here
look so done this is the first time is
your phone will be for leaving somebody
did not over the time it's Matt he was
actually quite invisible okay I was
acting like within all Jenna knives
videos excuse me I'm sorry
that was good one right for duty it's
that how I have the bronzer in it okay
we're leaving
I had the best time ever by the time to
pack up your body no come back the door
my purse wallet